hello everyone
i
am excited and curious and don't know
what to expect from today's video which
i do have to tell you is sponsored by
epic games
but um what we're about to play
i don't even know if play is the right
one which is what's really cool about it
this is a matrix awakens
unreal engine 5 experience that is
literally what it's called it's
available now free interactive
entertainment experience on the
playstation 5 and the series s and x
um for xbox
and they described it as being um
i can read it an experience that
illustrates the future of interactive
entertainment and storytelling
with unreal engine 5 that showcases the
start of an exciting new era for
creators and players alike naturally
i've been super curious about this very
excited to play it um
and they did send me a brief
and when i was reading over some of it i
decided actually that i shouldn't
anymore because i think
this is going to be really cool and i
don't know what to expect so i have not
seen any footage of it i really don't
know what this is going to be
i'm going to be finding out in real time
with all of you and i'm very very
excited i think it it i don't know it
sounds awesome so
let's
jump into it
back to game
okay
and to the matrix i guess we have
settings down here i will turn subtitles
on for everybody okay
let's go
um
i can't remember the last time that i
turned something on and was like what's
this gonna be
literally what are you
who is this sm fmv
this looks like fmv
oh my i'm thomas anderson
like many of you i work with computers
that's actually him
outside those categories of the real
world
but computers are also mirrors
reflecting back who and what we are in
the choices we make
the worlds we build
they also confront us with questions
about why we want to choose this or that
why we want to make x instead of a y
i'm assuming this isn't who we are
and yeah i believe this is actually
import directed by define
for instance i'm not even sure why i'm
here
i remember um lana wachowski used to
come here it was yeah that it was
important for me to ask people
how do we know what is real
now he's a video game
hi was he real before is that what you
meant to do oh no
i first played the character by thomas
anderson in the matrix trilogy those
films pioneered digital cinema with
shots like bullet time back then we
talked a lot about where the digital age
might take cinema and narrative
in an industry where actors have tried
to remain
wow
we wondered about digital faces that
could become immortal
hi
i'm carrie anne moss and i play trinity
in the matrix films 20 years ago we
asked ourselves how long it would be
this is cool
it does have actual uh
gameplay i don't know interactivity
this is basically an opening cut scene
what would reality mean
when a world we can build feels as real
as our own
oh
what just happened yeah this is
what they wanted
they said they were fine with your
theoretical mumbo jumbo but sorry i
realize i'm not saying very much i'm
saying it in my face
i'm very intrigued
[Music]
who said
the marketing people
marketing
is this just all
unreal engine
you five got it
like riding a bike
i sometimes miss like the environments
or is it both
they've really done me they've really
done me here sorry i was told this is a
sim preparing me to fight the system
right on
do you know about this yeah
it's all supposed to be a little
unreal
it's like that dusted they were dead
see you soon
i kind of appreciate the the marketing
jabs because this was made by a team of
creatives lana wachowski john gaida
jerome plateau i hope i'm pronouncing it
quickly and kim la berry
along with the epic game special
products and unreal engine teams
[Music]
okay
i'm like shocked by how good this looks
what the hell
oh oh oh no oh man might be on our car
now that's my butt that's my back that's
my back
get away from me
oh no oh no oh no
i did bad
[Music]
dude the buildings
hang on
[Music]
i'm not nuts right like this looks
incredible
the the world looks incredible
the cause
damn
[Music]
none of this pod is sponsored they
wanted me to play it they didn't ask me
to say anything about how it looks this
is all me
damn
oh my god
oh oh i thought that i was shooting
civilians and i was not
get out of here i'm too close i don't
like it your turn
you two
i'm sorry i don't know
[Music]
i guess they kind of don't count do they
hold steady
i fully believe that this is all in
eight
[Music]
[Music]
very matrix of you very nice very nice
very nice
[Music]
[Music]
i'm assuming this is the part where it
becomes open world
because i i'm pretty sure it does
this so this whole thing is intended to
be
it is supposed to be a demonstration of
performance and reliability unreal
engine 5 offers which is clearly what it
has done
the reflections and nuts
the shadows
um
and the project cinematic features the
performance and like this account yet we
know that open walled city environment
includes hero characters made in
metahuman creator okay i guess we'll
find out about that too i'm gonna again
try not to spoil it for myself
[Music]
whoa
i'm having a moment you guys
i hope that my footage does this justice
this looks incredible
look at that
i i'm shook the size of it
okay it has
thousands of agents
these ai and simulation systems that are
incredibly dense i could look into those
i guess
it's funny they have a note here that
says if you use a face camera recording
we recommend having it on for authentic
reactions to the experience that's a lot
of confidence that is them being like we
think you're gonna like it
okay let's go see what what
what happened to me bump into you
that's pretty solid
or if i can see anybody repeat it
look at these cars
i'm shook
i don't think i've ever just stood in a
video game and been like hmm i'm gonna
stand in the middle see how they react
you'll just walk around me
[Music]
oh my god
okay um let's uh pick a car pick a car
any car
i'm gonna pick a taxi
excuse me my taxi
oh no that's the wrong button uh what
was drive
x
i don't remember
uh oh maybe i have to pick a parked eye
on my
favorite cause over here
at least it looks like an x okay
look at that street
oh my god
do you
ugh
do you all understand how exciting this
is
oh
okay what's that
let me just get out real quick what is
this
um
because here's the thing
if this is like a fully rendered city
and i guess we'll see if we have any
loading screens
there meant to be a jump park somewhere
in the city full of ramps like this one
noted
um
stuff like this can straight up change
video games here's the thing that i
think about often
that really like gets me excited about
this kind of thing video games are
currently limited by hardware um not by
imagination there are plenty of things
that are imagined and and hugged for in
game development across the board that
aren't
possible yet due to hardware limitations
i should say monetary limitations but
the reality is it's it's hard way the
hardware makes
that's cool
make certain things expensive oh my god
oh my god
um there is absolutely a future in which
we can have and i mean this certainly
doesn't seem far off
fully functional um open world cities
millions of npcs uh millions of
buildings that you could enter
all of that good stuff
we just aren't there yet um you could
have a a full entire world recreated in
a video game
hey maybe we have maybe we all have a
simulation man uh
if
we didn't have like memory limitations
effectively which which yeah is the same
as basically having a monetary
limitation
and i think it's so exciting that we
don't yet know how far we'll get in our
lifetime in terms of how far video games
will go this is a pretty good testament
no pop in for all that that far away
i'm gonna just drive to one of those
buildings
i
okay so obviously getting a little bit
framing when i go real fast um i
really want to see
what the like tech channels
are going to do
to break this down this is really cool
it just keeps going it just keeps going
how big is it where does it end i want
to find the edge so there are definitely
things that you can do in this you can
get to like the top of some high
buildings and
man
i want to stream it
um
i think there are like some collectibles
around the world that you can find
obviously there's that jump park there
is like a couple of actions they've set
up for this
but i'm gonna make my golf find a job
map
this is
wild man
[Music]
the city looks so good the buildings
holy hell
oh no oh no oh it's fine it's fine it's
a matrix it's fine
can i drive over there
i don't remember
the layout of
manhattan all that well to be honest
which is where it seems like i am
i would guess right now i'm on the wrong
side brooklyn is on the other side but i
don't know
sorry about that friend
this is
nuts
i think i'm on the wrong side but i
don't know what that is over there
i'm foreign
i'm from a land far far away
good to see your trees work
i'm thinking i need to cross to the
other side but i'm not positive or it's
just they've just not lopped off the
bridges which would make
sense that that's the limits it's just
this juan island
is there a map
there is a map oh okay they have they
have they have
what are the markers for i wonder
what's that yellow marco
this is wild
um
yellow marker it was like right here
what is it
i see you
shall i fly
altitude up
oh there was a thing over there
well let's just go up anyway
speed up
this is amazing
it goes so far
oh maybe it's not manhattan
because i don't see like central park
could just be like miscellaneous new
yorkish looking city i have no idea i
don't know where i am what is this
drone oh that's probably what i'm on now
sun rotation ah world settings huh
that's cool
matrix filter
oh
i didn't even realize it was old
wow
okay
i kind of want to go to like a super
high building
though i do feel like i should go get
that no it's fine it's fine it's fine
i'm gonna fly over this way don't mind
me
the sounds are all different up here too
my gosh
tallest building
looks like it's going to be you my
friend
right
i think so yeah
let's go
hi there
i made it
damn it
got so close i was like is it gonna drop
me the whole way down it could
wow
this is
very very very cool um
they gave me a list of things you can do
so there are 27 of those info monuments
in the city
tallest building i found that
find the residence monument take a look
what they're watching on tv
oh there's so the monuments can do
different things one of them can change
the lighting
to turn it to night time
very cool there are 38 000 drivable
vehicles
[Music]
check out vehicle destruction no two car
crashes are the same let's have a look
test out vehicle destruction you say
don't mind if i do
okay
so you
completely different
yeah they're right that's actually
because often you know if you if you
play a game where you can crash into
vehicles
they will um
like you'll get the same kind of dents
just because they're like kind of close
by um sorry if they're in same same area
of the car i'm distracted
even that looked different the gloss
shadow
whoa
you're studying
this is wild
my gosh
wow
oh okay so the city's inspired by it's
like a mix of chicago san francisco and
new york
that makes sense
and there are 35
000 pedestrians
oh my gosh
at all times i guess i i haven't seen
anybody pop in
i hope this is interesting i don't i'm
just so impressed
oh oh my
[Music]
kind of just want to like look in in
shops and stuff you got nice plants in
there
got your convenience stores
what's this
a little dinah
office
robby you telling me video games gonna
look like this is that what you're
trying to tell me
i'm sorry oh she's holding a coffee got
your coffee cup
i just kind of want to observe
yeah i don't know if most people will
find this interesting what i'm doing
right now
look at her hair
it's just observing as somebody who
really loves video games you know
people watching tv up there they're
watching the news by the looks of it
wow
okay i feel like i could do this forever
i'm very impressed and will spend more
time in this um but i won't force all of
you to uh
to have to watch me do it the whole time
this is really really really really
impressive all right let me just fly to
the top one more time
it's altitude up speed up
people are gonna like legitimately be
making full movies
in video games i used to do that
actually in movie maker
but like
they'll look good
look at that
what you doing
oh your tiny new york apartments
sometimes it do be like that
i'm gonna just go back to this monument
up here
almost like here i think
unless the tall building's over there i
think this is it
hello there my friend
there are 7 000 buildings in the city
and this is the tallest one at 456
meters high
i distracted myself again um yes i will
not bore you guys with just me being
amazed by this
this is so cool
wow i can't wait to see what game devs
think of it
my gosh
very very very impressive um
so yes this video is sponsored by epic
but all of my reactions are extremely
genuine i promise this is so so so
impressive
holy hell
very cool
um
it is called the matrix awakens unreal
engine 5 experience it's available right
now as a free interactive entertainment
experience on the sony playstation 5 and
microsoft series s
and x
um i'll leave a link in the description
and in
the pin comment to where you can um
check it out yourself certainly does
make you wonder if we're in a simulation
yep existential crisis
i mean
my gosh this is cool
um thank you all for watching i will see
you guys next time